Yup, this is a branded Kentucky Fried Chicken phone, newly available in China.
Well, it turns out Asian countries are pretty obsessed with the chain.
Japan has been crazy over the Colonel's spices ever since a marketing campaign...
...turned visiting the fast food chain on Christmas into a tradition.
Okay, I'm stuck.
The high-tech collaboration with Chinese phone maker Huawei...
...is to celebrate the chain's 30th anniversary of selling buckets of chicken there.
And based on the phone's specs, we think the Colonel would approve.
We certainly hope so.
Our entire marketing campaign depends on it.
The seven-inch phone in KFC red comes with a KFC app and something called K-Music,...
...which lets you pick the restaurant's music, which for me would be the chicken dance.
You can buy the phone for a respectable $161.